>> I'm very happy to welcome
Amanda Palmer to Google
and today she's going to
be accompanied by cellist,
Zoe Keating.
Amanda is a performer,
director, composer,
and musician.
She is, to quote New York
rock critic,
"A type of performer that
all other musicians
should aspire to be.
Bold, broad,
touching and fearless,
playing with her entire body,
sobbing and shaking,
completely focused --"
[applause]
Amanda: Thank you.
Amanda: Hi. Does everybody
work here?
>> Yes.
Amanda: Is it--
is it -- yeah.
Is it totally weird to be doing
this in the middle of the day?
Or do you guys do this,
like, every day?
Okay.
>> Me, too.
♪ [playing piano]
Amanda: So, umm,
I think what we're gonna do is
I'm gonna play a few songs
with my good friend Zoe here
who is an amazing cellist
from the area,
and maybe you know her already. She's awesome.
And, umm,
then I'll do a couple
of songs along,
and then we're gonna do a
special project together,
a special Google project...
Involving you.
But before that
we'll do normal stuff.
Are you ready?
♪ [playing piano slowly]
Amanda: ♪ Blake says no-one
ever really loved him.
♪ They just faked it to get
money from the government.
♪ And Blake thinks angels grow
when you plant angel dust.
♪ He shakes his head and blinks
his pretty eyes but trust me.
♪ He's no valentine,
♪ though he said
he would be mine.
♪ His heart is in
Alaska all the time.
♪ Blake stays underwater
for the most part.
♪ He collects loose change
for all tomorrow's parties.
♪ And when Blake dates girls
with tattoos of the Pyramids.
♪ He breaks their hearts by
saying it's not permanent.
♪ But in his velvet mind.
♪ He believes with
all his might.
♪ [playing piano slowly]
♪ We'll all go to
Alaska when we die.
♪ [playing piano slowly]
♪ Blake makes friends
but only for the minute.
♪ He prefers the things he
orders from the internet.
♪ And Blake's been having
trouble with his head again.
♪ He takes his pills but
never takes his medicine.
♪ He tells me that he's fine.
♪ [playing piano and cello slowly]
♪ And the sad thing is he's right.
♪ And when it's two o'clock,
♪ he feels like dying.
♪ [playing piano and cello slowly]
♪ Blake says he is sorry
he got through to me.
♪ If it's OK,
♪ he'll call right back
and talk to the machine.
♪ Blake says it looks
like acid rain today.
♪ He takes the fish inside,
♪ he's very kind that way.
♪ But just like Caroline.
♪ He doesn't seem to mind.
♪ The globe is getting
warmer all the time.
♪ It's still cold in Alaska.
♪ It's still cold in Alaska. ♪
♪ [playing piano slowly]
[applause]
Amanda: Thank you.
Amanda: This is weird.
[laughing]
Amanda: So you know.
I mean, it's -- yeah.
You're not drinking,
it's not night.
It's weird.
[laughing]
Amanda: We're in a place
of work.
Okay. You guys start
drinking around 3:00?
Amanda: [laughing]
Amanda: Is there
a Google Bar?
>> Building 50.
Amanda: We'll be heading
to Building 50 after the show.
[laughing]
Amanda: Sounds good.
♪ [playing piano]
♪ [playing piano and cello loudly]
Amanda: ♪ Is it enough
to have some love
♪ Small enough to
slip inside a book
cover with your hand
♪ Because everyone around
you wants to look
♪ Is it enough to have some love
♪ Small enough to fit
inside the cracks
♪ The pieces don't fit
together so good
♪ With all the breaking
all the gluing back.
♪ And I am still not
getting what I want
♪ I want to touch the back
of your right arm
♪ I wish you could
remind me who I was
♪ Because every day I'm
a little further off
♪ But you are, my love,
♪ the astronaut flying
in the face of science
♪ I will gladly stay
an afterthought
♪ Just bring back
some nice reminders.
♪ [playing piano and cello
at moderate tempo]
Amanda: ♪ Is it getting
harder to pretend
♪ That life goes on without
you in the wake
♪ And can you see the means
without the end
♪ In the random frantic
action that we take
♪ Is it getting easy
not to care
♪ Despite the many rings
around your name
♪ It isn't funny
and it isn't fair
♪ You've traveled all this way
and it's the same
♪ But you are, my love,
the astronaut
♪ Flying in the face of science
♪ I will gladly stay
an afterthought
♪ Just bring back
some nice reminders.
♪ [playing piano and cello
at moderate tempo]
♪ I would tell them anything
to see you split the evening
♪ But as you see I do not
have an awful lot to tell
♪ Everybody's sick for something
that they can find fascinating
♪ Everyone but you and even
you aren't feeling well.
♪ [playing piano and cello
at moderate tempo]
♪ Yes you are,
♪ my love,
the astronaut
♪ Crashing in the name
of science
♪ just my luck they found
your upper half
♪ It's a very nice reminder
♪ [playing piano and cello
at moderate tempo]
♪ And you may be acquainted
with the night
♪ But I have seen the darkness
in the day
♪ and you must know it is
a terrifying sight
♪ because you and I are
living the same way. ♪
[applause]
Amanda: Thank you. This is Zoe
Keating, ladies and gentleman.
[applause]
Amanda: Okay. Today we have, um
We have prepared a special
cover song for you.
>> [laughing]
Zoe: Yes. Very difficult.
[Zoe and Amanda giggling]
[playing piano and cello]
♪ [playing piano and cello]
Amanda: ♪ Sometimes I feel
I've got to.
♪ Get away I've got to.
♪ Run away.
♪ From the pain that you
drive into the heart of me.
♪ The love we share.
♪ Seems to go nowhere.
♪ And I've lost my light.
♪ For I toss and turn
I can't sleep at night.
♪ Once I ran to you.
♪ Now I'll run from you.
♪ Oh, this tainted love
you've given.
♪ I give you all a boy
could give you.
♪ Take my tears and
that's not nearly all.
♪ Tainted love.
♪ Now I know I've got to.
♪ Get away I've got to.
♪ Run away.
♪ You don't really want it
any more from me.
♪ To make things right.
♪ You need someone
to hold you tight.
♪ And you'll think love is to pray.
♪ But I'm sorry I don't pray
that way.
♪ Once I ran to you.
♪ Oh,
♪ Now I'll run from you.
♪ Oh, this tainted love
you've given.
♪ I give you all a boy
could give you.
♪ Take my tears and
that's not nearly all.
♪ Tainted love.
♪ Don't touch me please.
♪ I cannot stand
the way you tease.
♪ I love you though
you hurt me so.
♪ Now I'm going to pack
my things and go.
♪ Tainted love,
tainted love.
♪ Touch me baby,
♪ Tainted love.
♪ [playing piano and cello]
[clapping] Amanda: Thank you very much, everyone.
[Cheering and clapping]
Amanda: Zoe Keating, ladies
and gentleman, on the cello.
[Cheering and clapping]
♪ [playing piano]
Amanda: Hi.
Amanda: ♪ Coin operated boy.
Sitting on the shelf
he is just a toy
But I turn him on
and he comes to life.
Automatic joy.
That is why I want a coin
operated boy
Made of plastic and elastic.
He is rugged and long-lasting
Who could ever ever
ask for more?
Love without complications
galore
Many shapes and weights
to choose from
I will never leave my bedroom
I will never cry at night again
Wrap my arms around him
and pretend...
Coin operated boy
All the other
real ones that I destroy.
♪ Cannot hold a candle to my new
boy and I'll never let him go.
And I'll never be alone.
And I'll never let him go.
And I'll never be go
And I'll never be go.
And I'll never be alone
Not with my coin operated boy...
This bridge was written to
make you feel smittener
With my sad picture of
love getting richer
Can you extract me from
my plastic fantasy?
I didn't think so but
I'm still convinceable
Will you persist even
after I kiss you
Goodbye for the last time?
Will you keep on
trying to prove it?
I'm dying to lose it
I'm losing it.
My comfort is I want it
♪ I want it
♪ I want a...
♪ coin operated boy
♪ [playing piano]
♪ And if I had a star to wish on
♪ For my life I can't imagine
♪ any flesh and blood would
be his match
♪ I can even take him in the bath
♪ Coin operated boy
♪ He may not be real experienced
with girls
♪ But I know he feels like
a boy should feel
♪ Isn't that the point?
♪ That is why I want a.
[Tempo slows]
♪ Coin operated boy
♪ With his pretty coin
operated voice
♪ Saying that he loves me.
♪ That he's thinking of me
♪ Straight and to the point
♪ That is why I want
♪ A coin operated boy. ♪
♪ [playing piano slowly
and lightly]
[applause]
Amanda: Thank you.
Amanda: So, umm...
I have one more song
and, umm, I think --
well, I have this, uh,
I have this idea that
I wanted to, umm,
I wanted to make a video
with you guys but --
but that you wouldn't
have to do very much
and I knew that we wouldn't really have time
to put anything together.
And, umm,
some of you might already know
that I sing this song called
"I Google You".
Did any of you know that?
>> Yeah.
Amanda: Okay.
So I thought it might be awesome to do the "I Google You"
A Google video involving and
starring Google.
Umm,
but I really wasn't quite sure
what to do and I came in here,
I was sound checking it
and, umm,
I realized that, umm,
the song actually -- 'cause
I've been playing it on tour
and the song doesn't really
work without a disco ball.
And I was like, "Oh. If only
we had a disco ball."
And then, like, some awesome guy just showed up and was like
"Oh of course we have a disco
ball -- [laughing]
Amanda: -- here at Google." [laughing]
'Cause you guys have everything.
You've got a bar,
and sushi,
and a disco ball.
So, we have here
this disco ball.
Umm, thank you!
[Clapping]
Amanda: And, umm,
here's where I start
to run into a problem.
Umm, so I was thinking that the concept of the video would be
that you would all be in here
and I would be playing the song
but you would all just
be on your laptops.
[laughing]
But then I didn't know if you
were all gonna bring your laptops
so I figured if you didn't have your laptop with you,
you could use a PDA,
or an iPhone,
or a -- or G1,
or whatever you've got.
Does everyone have
at least a thing?
Can you wave it in the air?
Can it --
Oh, you all [laughing]
And a sea of laptops filled
the air. [laughing]
Amanda: Umm, okay.
So how 'bout can we, umm,
can we fill in the front row
with at least a few people
that actually have laptops?
The only sad thing about
shooting this video is that
you won't be able
to watch me play
but you don't care about that.
You can watch the video.
Umm, and what we're gonna do --
I wanna introduce you guys to
Donna 'cause she's the one
who you've been watching running
around with a video camera.
This is Donna and she's
gonna shoot the video.
And, umm, and I need
some really, uh, like,
quintessential-looking Google employee to hold the disco ball.
[laughing]
You look -- you totally look like you work at Google.
Can you borrow someone's
glasses? [laughing]
Does anyone have a pair of,like, low level glasses he can borrow?
Preferably really, like,
you know, Google-looking?
[laughing]
>> Are these sufficient?
Amanda: Oh, my God.
You look awesome. [laughing]
You've got a cool T-shirt,
you've got your Google --
you're just Nathan.
Thank you. Okay.
So grab the disco ball.
Donna: Can we ask everyone here
to raise their hand
if they agree to be in
the video? [laughing]
And if anyone does not
want to be in the video
let me know and
raise your hand now.
Okay. You're still raising
your hand. Okay.
[laughing]
That's gonna be my video
release from all y'all
'cause Janet said I need one.
So we have one.
Thank you.
Amanda: We need one more laptop.
Yeah. Just look really bored.
Amanda: Like you'd rather
be at work right now.
[laughing]
Donna: Can we have you, umm,
just move in a little closer?
Yeah.
try to get an actual light,
lighting men.
>> Yeah. Do you have
those laser pointers?
Amanda: That's pretty good.
Yeah. Just for me.
A blank expression
looking bored. [laughing]
Yeah.
Just like that.
Like --
Donna: Here. I think we need your other hand.
Amanda: Oh, yeah.
Donna: That's awesome. But you gotta aim it right in there.
>> Ah.
[laughing]
Zoe: Him holding the flashlight
is an added bonus.
Donna: If you hold the thing up
and then hold the flashlight
underneath it'd look --
magic sparkles.
Awesome.
[laughing]
Donna: And, yeah.
Amanda: I would
rotate it very slowly.
>> How long can you
hold it like that?
>> Well, that's an interesting question.
[laughing]
>> How's that?
How long is this song? [laughing]
Amanda: This is --
I'm actually playing
the extended dance remix, so --
[laughing]
Amanda: It's 12 minutes. [laughing]
Amanda: No, it's not.
It's about --
I don't know.
It's, like, three minutes long.
It's not that bad.
So every --
everybody just look, uh,
really illuminated.
So when I start the
song make sure you, uh,
like, make sure your screens are
on and illuminating your faces.
And, umm --
you guys, too.
And, umm -- okay.
And, umm --
Donna: If we can have a little
more light on, umm,
on the house lights
on the audience
that would be wonderful
if I can see you guys.
Amanda: For added gravitas
I would ask you this
your motivation is to --
Think about --
think about some, uh,
think about some really
tragic ex-lover in your life.
And actually, you know, since
you're obviously online
you guys have wireless here.
It's Google.
Why don't you Google them?
[laughing]
Amanda : Think of like,
you know,
that person that you haven't
thought about from tenth grade
like you went out with for three
weeks before they dumped you.
Google them.
[laughing]
See what they're up to.
Amanda: No. No, no, no.
This song is all about pain.
[laughing]
Kind of.
Not really.
This song, umm,
just so you guys know
the background of the song,
the words were not
actually written by me.
They were written
by Mr. Neil Gaiman.
And -- who's over there. [applause]
Amanda: Umm, and, uh,
and he wrote the melody, too.
I just put the chords to it.
So that's the story.
♪ [playing piano]
Amanda : And I think, umm,
yeah.
Just to make sure --
are you gonna have enough light?
Donna: I'm checking
'cause I'd really
prefer to have it dark
with everybody's screen
glowing on them
instead of having the lights turned on.
Amanda: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do any of you guys PCs?
It's like a sea of Macs. [laughing]
Amanda: You're the renegade.
>> Right here.
Amanda: There's that one.
Donna: Speaking of
switching around.
Amanda: No, no. You should stop
on him accusingly.
[laughing]
Amanda: I should just be this
nice, slow pan and then oh.
Donna: What do we have here?
Amanda: Exactly.
Donna: Okay.
Amanda: Okay.
So, you guys,
make sure your screens are up as
bright as they can go and, umm-
Donna: 'Cause that's
my lighting.
Amanda: And I'm gonna start.
And don't -- and don't be
tempted to actually
be at all interested in
what I'm doing up here.
Donna: All right.
Amanda: Oh. Oh, they're sharing.
That's really beautiful. [laughing]
♪ [playing piano]
Amanda: Bored.
Amanda: All right.
Yeah.
We might do two takes if the
first one gets all screwed up.
Okay.
Ready everybody?
Google.
[laughing]
Google your ex-s.
Oh, yeah.
They don't care.
♪ [playing piano slowly]
Amanda: ♪ I Google you
♪ Late at night when I don't
know what to do
♪ [playing piano slowly]
♪ I find photos you've
forgotten you were in
♪ Put up by your friends
♪ I do, I Google you
♪ When the day is done and
everything is through
♪ I read your journal that
you kept that month in France
♪ I've watched you dance
♪ And I'm pleased your name
is practically unique
♪ It's only you and a would-be
PhD from Chesapeake
♪ Who writes papers on
the structure of the sun
♪ I've read each one
♪ I think that I should
let you fade
♪ But there's that box
and there's your name
♪ Somehow it never makes
the pain grow less or fade
♪ or disappear I think that
I should save my soul
♪ and I should crawl back
in my hole
♪ But it's too easy just to fold
and type your name again, I fear
♪ I Google you
♪ When the day is done
and everything is through
♪ And each scrap of information
that I gather
♪ Says you've found somebody new
♪ And it really shouldn't matter
♪ Ought to blow up my computer
♪ But instead...
♪ I Google you. ♪
[playing piano slowly]
[applause and laughter]
Donna: Do you think we can
do it one more time?
>> Give me a minute, yes.
Donna: You could turn around.
>> Yeah.
Amanda: Umm, I don't know.
>> You look a little dark. [laughing]
Donna: No, no.
You look, like, dark.
Amanda: Yeah. I feel like
we should add like
one random thing.
Like -- like. [laughing]
You know, somebody
in a bear suit.
Do you guys have a bear
suit at Google?
>> Uh, no. But we have lots
of playful colored balls.
Amanda: Oh, wait.
Who had the idea about
the bean bags earlier?
Yeah. Do you wanna grab
the bean bags
or are they far away?
Are a couple of guys willing
to maybe lounge in bean bags?
Just so we can switch
it up a little bit?
Yeah, yeah.
Put them in the light.
I'm just thinking --
yeah.
Like different places
for people to be bored.
I think what would be funny is
if we had everybody here
but you actually filmed a little
bit into the recesses
of his face and there were
people on their devices
in strange ways.
See what I mean?
Like --
like, you know,
like somebody, you know,
somebody with their legs up
against the wall in a yoga pose
but, like, texting.
[laughing]
[People talking
in the background]
Donna: Who wants to be
on the bean bag?
Amanda: Someone can sit
on the ball.
Umm, if anyone has
any random ideas,
now is the time to put
your creativity to work.
That's awesome.
[laughing]
Yeah?
Oh, yeah.
I don't know.
I feel like they're --
I feel like applause
would be against
the spirit of the boredom.
Oh, wait.
Actually, could we do this?
[Man talking in the background]
Amanda: [laughing]
No. Actually,
I don't know if it would
be stupid we could do --
I could -- we could --
I could cue you because
I wouldn't be in the shot
but if you want, umm,
Donna, if you wanna pan
to them at the end
and I could just, umm,
I could just wave my hand
and when I wave my hand
if you could all, just look up.
Well, no.
Kinda.
You can see out of the corner
of your eye maybe
and if you hear a great shuffle
of heads.
[laughing]
Would that --
it might kinda work.
Or actually, I mean,
it could just be at the
very end of the song.
Like, after I hit that last
note give it a beat
and then kind of all look up
at the same time
and then look down again
at your computers. [laughing]
Don't applaud.
Yeah. The Google shirt
is pretty beautiful.
[Woman talking in
the background]
Amanda: Yeah, yeah.
Give him the bean bag.
Zoe, can you do something
weird with your cello?
'Cause there's that great light
behind you and it --
the cello looks awesome
in silhouette.
Whatever you do,
just make sure you're
also on a device.
>> Where do you
want the bean bag?
Amanda: Someone could
give you a phone or something
or they could --
Donna: [Talking in the background]
Amanda: You know what also
might be good
if you actually got a shot of, umm,
when we're over here maybe get a
shot of somebody's back actually
-- can you just
Google some ex-love,
some ex-anything?
[Talking in the background]
[laughing] [Clapping]
Amanda: Yeah. I think that'll
give it a little bit more --
[Talking in the background]
>> There's a bunch of wires
coming out of this.
[People chatting in the background]
Donna: Move the mic a little bit --
Is that a yes or no?
Bad idea?
Okay.
All right.
[laughing]
[People chatting in the background]
Donna: So, you guys,
at the end of the song
I'm gonna be here
so when you hear that last note
just lift your heads up --
Amanda: Yeah. And I'll
make it really obvious.
I'll do.
♪[playing piano]
Donna: Up and then count
to three. One,
two,
three
down.
Amanda: [laughing]
That's gonna be hilarious.
I know. Can anyone else think
of an ending to this
that would be ironic and good?
[laughing]
I mean, that's gonna be pretty funny.
I feel like you should all go
beat up the guy with the PC.
[laughing]
I really depends on whether
we want an optimistic ending
or a pessimistic ending.
Right now it's pretty sad.
[laughing]
No. We will leave it as it is.
Umm, why don't you -- Donna, after you --
after you come off of him.
Donna: Yeah?
Amanda: Umm,
okay.
After you come off of them why
don't you do a -- come to me
and I'll kind of give it a look of,
like WTF.
Okay.
Donna: Are we good?
Amanda: Sure. Well, you know,
that's kinda distracting.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's do that.
So come in to me and I'll
sort of give a [Sighing]
Donna:[Talking in the background]
Donna: I wanted to ask you
to turn it a lot slower.
Amanda: Yeah.
It's just moving.
Donna: If you wanna change
hands you can move it around.
[Talking in the background]
Amanda: Yeah.
Once the camera's not on you.
Okay. Are we ready
to get our art on?
Donna: Everybody over here
looking good.
All right.
We are rolling.
♪ [playing piano]
Amanda: I think I'm also --
I'm not gonna do the long intro.
I'm just gonna start.
I think that's gonna be better.
♪ [playing piano]
[Talking in the background]
Amanda: Oo. Someone gave
Zoe an iPhone.
[laughing]
♪ [playing piano]
♪ I...
Donna:[Talking in the background]
Amanda : A little better?
Okay.
[laughing]
Amanda: [Breathes deeply]
♪ I Google you
♪ Late at night
when I don't know what to do
♪ I find photos you've
forgotten you were in
♪ Put up by your friends
♪ I do, I Google you
♪ When the day is done and
everything is through
♪ I read your journal that you
kept that month in France
♪ I've watched you dance
♪ And I'm pleased your name
is practically unique
♪ It's only you and a would-be
PhD from Chesapeake
♪ Who writes papers on
the structure of the sun
♪ I've read each one
♪ I think that I should
let you fade
♪ But there's that box
and there's your name
♪ Somehow it never makes
the pain grow less or fade
♪ or disappear I think that
I should save my soul
♪ and I should crawl back
in my hole
♪ But it's too easy just to
fold and type your name again,
♪ I fear I Google you
♪ When I'm all alone and feeling blue
♪ [piano playing]
♪ And each scrap of information
that I gather
♪ Says you've found somebody new
♪ And it really shouldn't matter
♪ Ought to blow up my computer
♪ But instead...
♪ I Google you. ♪
♪ [Piano playing slowly]
Amanda: Don't be sad.
I know this is getting
really depressing.
[laughing]
Amanda:[laughing]
I think you can clap.
[applause]
Amanda: That was --
that was really good.
Do you guys have one more in you?
I know that it's really strenuous.
[laughing]
Amanda: [laughing]
Amanda: I think we --
we kind of missed the end.
I feel like we should do
something more obvious, eh?
Donna: [Talking in the background]
Amanda: Oh, from where you are?
Amanda: Yes, maybe we'll just
leave the end like it is.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay. So skip the end this time
but that's a great shot.
It's very "La Vie en Rose "
except at Google.
[laughing]
[Talking in the background]
Amanda: Yeah. Maybe towards
the end hold
whatever you got a little
closer to your face.
Donna: [Talking in the background]
Amanda: Awesome.
Okay. So we'll do one last take of this
and then we'll just
pick the best of three.
And, umm, I think just to --
I wouldn't show.
I would just -- I would
let her come find you.
Donna: [Talking in the background]
Amanda: Yeah. Just ignore her.
[laughing]
Are you holding that up?
Donna: [Talking in the background]
Amanda: Okay. All right.
Last take.
Here we go.
Jared, how you doin'?
It's good?
Are you bummin'?
>> No.
Amanda: Okay.
[laughing]
All right.
Last take and then
we'll wrap it.
♪ [playing piano]
Amanda: You're a hero, dude.
[Talking in the background]
Amanda: And one --
♪ [playing piano]
[Talking in the background]
Amanda: All right.
♪ [playing piano]
♪ [playing piano slowly]
Amanda: Everybody ready?
Okay.
We are rolling.
Amanda: Ready?
♪ [playing piano slowly]
Amanda: ♪ I Google you
♪ Late at night when I don't
know what to do
♪ I find photos you've
forgotten you were in
♪ Put up by your friends I do.
♪ I --
Donna: Sorry, guys.
It's my fault.
Amanda: This is what rock
stars actually do all day.
It's really boring.
♪ [playing piano slowly]
Amanda: You ready? Okay.
Amanda: I'm for real.
♪ [playing piano slowly]
♪ I Google you
♪ Late at night when I don't
know what to do
♪ I find photos you've
forgotten you were in
♪ Put up by your friends I do,
♪ I Google you
♪ When the day is done and
everything is through
♪ I read your journal that
you kept that month in France
♪ I've watched you dance
I've YouTubed you
♪ And I'm pleased your name
is practically unique
♪ It's only you and a would-be
PhD from Chesapeake
♪ Who writes papers on
the structure of the sun
♪ I've read each one
♪ I know that I should
let you fade
♪ But there's that box
and there's your name
♪ Somehow it never makes
the pain grow less or fade
♪ or disappear I think that
I should save my soul
♪ and I should crawl back
in my hole
♪ But it's too easy just to
fold and type your name again,
♪ I fear I Google you
♪ When I'm all alone and feeling blue.
♪ And each scrap of information
that I gather
♪ Says you've found somebody new
♪ [playing piano]
♪ And it really shouldn't matter
♪ Ought to blow up my computer
♪ But instead...
♪ I Google you. ♪
♪ [playing piano]
Amanda: Okay. We're done.
[laughing] [applause]
Amanda: That's going to be surreal
YouTube clip of the day tomorrow.
Thank you guys.
I don't know.
Did we --
did we hit 2:00 o'clock?
Long ago?
Okay.
If you guys aren't gonna kick me out
we were gonna do a really
quick Q and A
if you guys still wanna do it.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
And I can put my book out.
I don't know where it went.
Oh. I didn't know we were.
Yeah. Where are they?
Oh. Cool. Okay.
Yeah. You guys I have a book
that just is coming out
right now.
It's not that one.
You guys have the wrong book?
Oh. Yeah.
Okay.
Well, if you guys play piano
you can buy that one.
This comes out this week and you
can get it online and it's --
it's a book called
"Who Killed Amanda Palmer"
and it's got stories by Neil,
Mr. Neil Gaiman,
and a bunch of photos of me that --
in different places.
It's a really exciting book.
God. I feel like people are gonna think
I'm a really depressing
artist today. [laughing]
What with all the sad songs
and the dead pictures.
But you can come look at it.
I'll leave it out.
And I was gonna --
is Zoe still back there?
You wanna come up?
I thought, umm,
if you guys felt like it I thought
we could do a really quick
I don't even think
I need this --
we can do a really quick Q
and A given that-- we're, like,
two of the geekiest musicians I know.
Umm,
and, yeah.
Yeah, yeah. Why don't
you give Zoe the mic?
Umm
Yeah. You can ask us questions.
We're massive twitterers.
[laughing]
And we're, uh,
umm, you know,
Zoe is --
I'm on a major label.
But I'm trying desperately to get off
and Zoe has been
independently awesomely
doing her thing for a while.
So yeah. If you guys have
any questions about anything,
hit us.
[inaudible question]]
Amanda: What did I what?
Amanda: Because there are
kids in the house. [laughing]
[laughing]
Amanda: Any -- anybody else?
Yeah?
[inaudible question]]
Amanda: Umm, you know,
I compose in my head
and I use -- I mean,
I've played piano all my life
but I've been -- more and more
I've been composing just,
you know, songs for whatever
and then trying to figure out
how to produce them
when I put them onto --
onto record. But,
I mean, I don't play any other
instrument
with any kind of proficiency.
I'm a hack ukulele lay lee player but,
umm,
speaking of which. Oh, yeah.
I forgot about that.
I think I left it upstairs.
Umm, but yeah.
I mean, really --
if you listen to my records
it's all piano based.
That might change on my next record,
actually.
Umm, because I'm not --
Like I really don't consider myself
a piano player.
I'm okay at it
but I'm not great.
And my records aren't really
about the piano playing.
They're about the songs.
So.
Yeah?
[inaudible question]]
Amanda: Any more scoring?
Have I done any scoring?
[laughing]
Umm, that's Zoe's job.
Zoe does the scoring.
Uh, I -- you know,
if asked, I would.
Umm,
Zoe does a lot of
film music and stuff.
I've never actually really been asked.
Zoe: Oh. Should I make that happen?
Amanda: Yeah.
Hook it up, Zoe.
Put me out.
Umm ...
you know, that's kind of embarrassing.
Do you use an iPod?
Zoe: Nope.
Amanda: Yeah. I don't really either.
Zoe: I don't listen to music at all.
Amanda: I have a --
yeah. No. Zoe --
Zoe and I neither of us
really listen to music.
And I know that sounds ridiculous
but I-- in the course of an average
day I just don't --
don't do it.
And I have an iPod
and it's got --
it's got, like, uh, you know,
yoga lessons on it.
Zoe: Yeah.
Amanda: [laughing] And some --
and mixes from my record
because I needed to, like,
carry them around.
But I think like, I was
a fanatic Walkman wearer
as a teenager as always had one.
like everywhere I went.
And I think, you know,
as I --
as I got older and,
like, the more I toured especially
I just --
there was always music
and noise around
and I find now that I can't --
I can't do --
I can't listen to music
and do anything else
at the same time.
I can't think even.
So unless I'm washing dishes.
Yeah. I can't handle it.
Uh, it's Frank Sinatra.
I mean, it depends.
I'm really obsessive, too.
Like I'll find a record that
I like and then
I'll just listen to that
for a couple months.
And sometimes it's an old record,
sometimes it's a new record.
I really like Tegan
and Sara's new record.
I -- I --
I really did --
I feel like last year I learned
at the beauty of Frank Sinatra
and I just listened to this
one record of his over,
and over, and over again.
I didn't like any of his other records.
I still don't. It's just that one.
Umm,
uh, "Come Dance with Me".
It's awesome.
Umm,
but yeah.
It's weird.
Like, music listening has changed.
Zoe and I wanted to start
a non-profit organization
called "Musicians for Less Music."
[laughing]
And I got --
I got into this --
I mean, this is a good --
is that even on?
Is your mic even on?
Zoe: I don't think so.
Oh, there it is.
Amanda: Umm, there's --
there's this thing
that's happening where, like,
I actually think
we have too much music.
I think we've -- I think we've
gone overboard and I was --
I was having this conversation
actually with some friends of Neil's
we were all sitting around
talking about, umm,
how -- I was talking about how I think
music has just been not --
not devalued but
it's lost its intimacy.
you know like, I used to have a record
collection and it was this big.
And I knew every record and
I knew basically all the songs
and all the records,
even the bad ones,
but I had a relationship
with the records.
And I feel like now with
the availability of everything
it's so hard to have a relationship
with an album,
like, a real one where you hold it
and you know it,
and you -- like, if you take it out
with a Walkman
you have to commit to just
listening to that record.
Like, you made a choice.
And I feel really fuddy duddy.
Zoe: It's like having, like,
ten different kinds of ketchup.
[laughing] You know.
Like, do you really need ten
different kinds of ketchup?
Amanda: Yeah. I --
it's really --
I mean, it's really interesting to see
what it's gonna do to people
and the way they relate to music.
It's gonna really change things.
Our idea was to just
limit the number of songs
in the world to 100.
[Talking in the background]
Amanda: What?
[inaudible question]
Amanda: Oh. Well, pretty
much everybody. [laughing]
But no.
But here's the point.
You can have a hundred songs
but as many variations of
those songs as you want.
So artists basically just
have those hundred songs
to pick from and they can perform
all of them. So ...
[inaudible quesiton]
Amanda: Exactly.
Zoe: This does break down once
you get so specifics
so we probably shouldn't go there.
Amanda: [laughing]
There would be wars.
>> Can you talk about
your theater projects?
Amanda: Umm, yeah. I mean,
I did a theater project
this past spring
with my high school,
umm, 'cause I really,
I worship the director
who was a real huge influence
on me in high school
and I sort of went back and
did an original workshop play
with the kids and it was great.
It was based on,
umm, loosely based on,
uh, a great modern album
that I actually really love
by Neutral Milk Hotel,
if you guys know them.
Umm, and they were playing
over the Seas.
So we basically used the music
as source material
and we wrote this story around
it and it was sort of about --
it used a lot of music from the album
and was sort of based around
Anne Frank.
And it was a really
beautiful play.
And you can see it --
it's up on USTREAM
and we're trying to get a better
edit of it up but, umm ...
I have a theater background.
That's where I came from.
And I'm always trying to do,
you know, not just live
in rock 'n' roll world
but I also do theater stuff.
>> So, what's your inspiration?
I grew up with a lot of
pictures of you dancing.
Amanda: Oh. 'Cause well,
I had a bunch like you do.
And, umm,
you know, I had a handful
and I was gonna use them
as album art work.
You know, I had been in
these various situations
where I wound up with pictures
of me dead.
I did a performance art project
in college
that had a bunch of dead
photos in it.
You know, when I was on tour
and I was sort of like
in a bad mood
I would go off early
in the morning
and take dead pictures
of myself and, you know,
in with the beautiful architecture
in Europe and whatever.
And I was gonna make
them album artwork but,
umm, my record label,
umm, who I don't get along
with very well,
gave me no packaging budget.
So I wanted to digipack
'cause --
because I wouldn't put out
a jewel case
but they wouldn't
give me a booklet.
So instead of complaining
I just decided to make a book.
And then it just grew
and I kept adding more
and more dead pictures,
and then Neil got involved
and wrote the stories,
and now it's --
now it's a whole thing.
So, it's actually it's like --
it's like a big glorified CD booklet
in spirit.
Umm, so, yeah. That's sorta
where the idea came from.
In the -- in the corner over there.
Yeah.
[inaudible question]
Amanda: Oh. Thank you.
Yeah. You ruined my life.
Yeah. But I forgive you personally.
What?
[inaudible question]
Amanda: Sure.
If you guys are wondering
what we're talking about
all of the Dress and Dolls
videos got pulled off of YouTube
during the Warner YouTube war.
Did you guys know about that?
Yeah, so-- My band was sadly
a casualty of that battle
and the videos are still not out.
Umm,
but things are actually --
things are looking okay with the label.
We're sort of in that negotiating phase
so I don't wanna talk too much
about it
but I think that I might be --
I might be set free.
Umm,
but,I mean,things are just
changing so fast
it's ridiculous.
And I just , you know,
actually, I've been
working on a big long,
umm, kind of manifesto --
not manifesto but, like,
a big long explanation.
Sort of not unlike the --
have any of you guys
read that e-mail that, umm,
Courtney Love wrote back
in 1999 or 2000?
It's -- hers is kind of irrelevant now
but it's in the same spirit
of basically like
this is how it breaks down.
Like, when I signed with
a major record label
I knew that I wasn't gonna make
any money on my recordings
'cause I was smart.
I was, like, okay.
I'm not trading this for that.
I'm not gonna make any
money on my recordings.
I can dupe my own CDs at home
myself so I don't --, you know,
like, I can see the direction
that things are going in.
Umm, and I'm trading their powerful
promotion for,
you know,
the lack of royalties that I'll
ever see 'cause I knew that.
But then the label sort
of stopped promoting.
They stopped promoting the band,
they stopped promoting me.
They, you know,
I put the Solar record out with them
because I had to, contractually,
and that was -- that was,
like, hugely disappointing
because it was this big
important record
and I made it with Ben Folds,
and I thought it was gonna
be really fancy
and then they just sort of did nothing.
And that's when I decided
I wanted to go.
Umm,
but it's really tough.
I mean, it's, like,
the human being in me just feels,
you know, so badly for anyone
working in a major label
because they're clinging
so desperately
to things that aren't working.
And they're trying,
and trying,
and they're trying to evolve
but they're so late in the game
it's just -- it's,
you know,
it's over.
Umm, meanwhile -- [laughing]
Meanwhile on twitter,
uh, things are actually
really exciting.
I mean, I'm doing shows
nowadays like,
you know, 12 hours in advance
where I just tell people to show up
in a field and they give me
they just give me cash.
[laughing]
It's awesome.
So, you know, I think --
but mostly when I write this blog --
you know, and hopefully it'll
circulate around and stuff --
umm --
the thing to explain
to a lot of people
in talking about it lately is as
a musician or artist in general
you have to learn that,
you know, superstardom isn't
really an option anymore
and you have to want to
be a working artist
willing to just make a living doing
what you're doing,
and willing to tour,
and willing to promote,
and willing to connect with your fans,
and be available and not just be,
you know, that old idea
we have from the 80s
of what it means to,
you know, to be a rock star,
be a musician.
'Cause it's just --
the system isn't set up
that way anymore.
Yeah?
>> What kind of difference
have you noticed
with personal interaction with fans?
How do you make yourself so
obsessed along that line?
[inaudible question]
Amanda: Well, I was always like that.
So there was never a difference
to detect.
I mean,
could you speak to that
at all in 'cause --
Zoe: No.
Amanda: You were in bands
before the internet
was really a thing.
Zoe: Yeah.
Amanda: But you were
in a grass roots band.
Zoe: In other words
I'm kinda old. [laughing]
Uh, I would say that, umm,
people nowadays just know
so much more about you
than they ever did before.
Amanda: Yeah.
Zoe: So, umm,
but, uh,
it's been such a gradual change.
I think I'm so used to that now.
Amanda: Yeah. I think
it's a personality thing
because there are plenty of artists
who still don't make themselves
accessible to their fans at all
even though they have a million
ways of doing it.
And there were artists
back before the, you know,
days of the internet making
everything so accessible
who were accessible simply
by going out
after shows and hanging
out with their fans.
And that's just a personality
thing I think.
And the internet has just
enabled those
who wanna be super connectors.
Zoe: I wanna say one other thing,
though,
is it becomes less of
an option not to interact.
Like, there's a lot of musicians
who really don't want to
interact with their fans
and it wasn't necessarily
so noticeable in the past.
But now if you're
one of the artists
who doesn't come out to sign
or doesn't make an effort
to stay in touch it can kill you.
Amanda: Yeah.
And it will.
Zoe: And it's really noticeable.
Amanda: That's still pretty
entitled I think nowadays
that they're gonna be able
to know a lot about you.
Zoe: Right.
Amanda: And that's fine
for me 'cause I like it.
Umm, but, you know,
for someone who just wants
to just sort of make music.
Zoe: But I think that for people
who are really introspective
and are not necessarily
extroverts --
Amanda: Be a sculptor.
Zoe: -- it's difficult.
[laughing]
Amanda: That's a really
good question, though.
I mean, I think about that a lot
because it sort of raises
that question of, like, okay.
So you wanna be a musician
nowadays
and you wanna actually
make money.
That really is sort of the job.
Like, the job is
to be connected,
and to be sociable,
and that was kind of always
the way
but I guess like Zoe said
you used to be able to
just hide and nowadays,
you know, everything you do
is instantly kinda public.
And I was thinking about that.
I was wondering, how, you know,
especially when you think about, like,
real big celebrities and stuff,
pretty much,
you know, the minute
you're out in public
your life is recordable,
it's archiveable,
and you're accountable
for everything you do
and the way you look
and you can't really --
can't really hide.
And when I think about that
I just feel really lucky
'cause I'm not the kind of
person who really wants to hide
'cause I'm the opposite of private.
But, umm, yeah.
But for those who aren't that's
gotta feel like a living hell.
Zoe: Uh-huh.
Amanda: And here we go being
depressing again. Sorry.
[laughing]
Amanda: Can someone else --
Zoe: I think it's the lighting.
Amanda: Yeah.
It's the lighting.
The lighting is kinda sad.
Zoe: And the lack of drinks.
Amanda: And the lack
of drinks. Yeah.
We'd be laughing about this
if we were ...
does anyone else have any
questions or should we wrap up?
'Cause I know it's getting kinda late.
[inaudible question]
Amanda: Can I what?
>> We have drinks at 4:30.
Amanda: Oo. I don't know.
Maybe.
Amanda: Umm, anything else?
Anything else that's quick?
Yeah?
>> Can I prevent file sharing?
Amanda: No.
[laughing]
Amanda: I was.
Zoe: However,
I would like to make a distinction
with that, however.
Amanda: Yeah. You should buy
Zoe's stuff.
Zoe: Yeah. Umm,
[laughing]
Zoe: You should buy my records.
I think that you should know
that for artists
who are not on record
labels file sharing,
uh, it's a different game
because there's no middlemen.
Like, with my CD,
if you buy my CD on iTunes,
it's only iTunes in
between you and me.
Umm, whereas if you were
to buy Amanda's CD
she's never gonna see anything.
However, but I pay my mortgage
with iTunes
so I care a little bit
more about file sharing.
But because I like file
sharing in some ways
'cause people can get the music
and I know that a very small
percentage of people will buy it
but since I get to
keep more of the profits
then that small percentage
that buys it
I can still pay my mortgage.
So ...
Amanda: Yeah. I mean,
I would -- I think that,
like, even I become independent
I'm still gonna encourage people
to file share because I --
like, I personally am working on
so many other different kinds
of revenue stream
assuming that people
who share my music
are going to come to my shows,
you know,
buy my merchandise,
get involved in projects,
buy this book.
Like, you know, I'm doing
that very deliberately
because I know that the music is,
like, even if we try
and I will continue to sell music
and, like, the people who
are the hard core fans
and who understand that that
money is going into my hand,
I will still be selling them
CDs and I will expect them,
you know, and hope that
they'll buy them
because the music's gonna
cost money to make.
But, umm,
but in general I think,
you know --
one of the things
I'm really hoping is that
music fans and the audience
can hopefully kind of change
its perception of what it means
to be a music fan
and that they will be less afraid
to just actively
support the artists that they listen to
and that it might not be
as direct as an exchange
where I pay you this amount of
money for this piece of music
but that it's sort of more
like a, umm,
a support system of patronage
where like your fans will know
to support you or tip you
and that, you know,
and that system will actually
evolve to exist in a way
that makes it, you know,
that makes sense.
I hope.
I'd like to think that that could work.
[inaudible question]
Zoe: You are too kind.
It's called "One Cello Times 16".
Yeah. [laughing]
>> Are you guys going to be
working together for recording?
Amanda: Uh, yeah.
We actually are.
Zoe: Yes.
Amanda: You wanna say about it?
I don't know how much
we're keeping secret but...
yeah. Well, we're hoping to, umm,
to do some kind of project
that's improv based sometime
soon because we just really
love playing with each other.
Zoe came on tour with me,
umm, I put this record out,
this "Who Killed Amanda" record
out it came out in September
and she came on tour
as the opening act
and also backed me up on stage
and we just really
liked working together.
So hopefully we'll do --
we'll do something soon I hope.
And, umm,
I think we should end.
But, umm,
I wanted to thank you guys
for having us and, umm,
if you wanna find out more
just go to --
my site is Amandapalmer.net
and Zoe's --
Zoe: Zoekeating.com.
Amanda: Yeah. And we're both
all over the internet so just go --
just Google us.
[laughing]
Amanda : And yeah. It's been
really wonderful being here.
Thank you guys.
Thank you also for lunch.
That was just awesome.
[laughing]
Amanda: And ridiculous.
Zoe: Will that lunch
still be there?
Can we have it again?
Amanda: Yeah.
[laughing]
Amanda: We're gonna have
to come back tomorrow.
Umm, but yeah.
I'm also --
I'm playing for those of
you who are in the area
I'm playing on Saturday
at the Fire Arts Festival
which is in Oakland.
It's actually a gig that
Zoe hooked me up with and, umm,
further south I'm playing in San Diego
at ComicCon next week
if any of you guys are headed down.
So --
and that's a benefit show
for the comic book
legal defense fund
and that's kind of it.
Umm, if you wanna stay connected
I really -- like,
I strongly, strongly, strongly
urge you
and beg you to sign my actual
e-mail list which is,
you know, will be really obvious
on the front page of my web site
and that's kind of it.
I think we've lumped
ourselves out and, umm,
and obviously the video
will be going out.
So you'll know. [laughing]
You'll know when that
video goes up because
someone will probably tell you.
But we'll try and get that up.
You know, it's a one-take thing
so we'll try and get it up
in the next couple days.
And that's it.
Thank you guys so much.
[applause]
Amanda: Zoe Keating.
Zoe: Thank you, guys.
[applause]